[music]
Let's get a [music] quick read of the
room. If you are coming from right here
in the Big Apple from New York, make
some noise.
Okay. Now, I have to say it. I assume
this is the biggest group. San
Francisco.
Wow, that is surprising. Uh, Austin.
Okay, we got Austin. Who thinks they
came from the furthest place and is in
the room today?
>> Where? Where?
>> Ecuador. Can anyone beat Ecuador?
>> New Zealand.
>> I don't think anyone's going to beat New
Zealand. There we go. Well, first of
all, uh, I am so excited to welcome you
all to the AI Engineer Code Summit 2025.
Uh, I'm Alex Lieberman, co-founder of
Morning Brew and your MC for the day.
Um, now you may be wondering, why is a
newsletter guy hosting an AI engineer
conference? It's a great question. Well,
after I left my role at Morning Brew, I
asked myself one simple question, and it
was, what space do I want to spend my
time in for the next 20 years where I
can build something consequential and
spend my time with some of the smartest
people I've ever met? And the answer
became obvious. I wanted to be as close
to the frontier of AI as humanly
possible. Which is why I co-founded
10x.co, Co. which is an AI
transformation firm helping mid-market
and enterprise companies learn how to
use AI within their business. And I
spend basically all of my time now with
AI engineers like yourselves. I'm the
only non-technical person in the
business and I wouldn't have it any
other way. So as you know this year has
been a banner year for the industry. And
I would think of today as both a look
back on where we've been as well as a
tactical view of where we are headed in
companies small and large, old and new.
We're going to hear from the labs. We'll
hear from Unicorn AI startups. We'll
hear from academics, big-time management
consultants, and Fortune50 brands. But
before we do that, we have to give the
brands that made this day possible their
flowers. So, let's go into it. Let's
give it up for Google DeepMind, today's
presenting sponsor. [applause]
Love it. Keep it going for Anthropic,
the platinum sponsor for the day.
[applause]
And then one more round of applause for
all of the gold and silver sponsors who
you can meet in the expo downstairs
throughout the day. One more. Let's keep
it going. [applause]
Are you guys ready to do the damn thing?
Let's do it. [music]
Heat up
>> [music]
>> here.